give wimy some credit he steps up when
the big names come to play whether it's
Joe lmb joic ad Giannis when the big
dogs come to town wimy always
game but there were no answers for this
guy tonight as he steps over with our
guy 3D all right thanks guys first of
all big fella take me through talking to
coach Brett Brown who you had some long
days with when he was head coach here ah
man you know that's obviously that's my
first coach and you know we have some
great moments so you know it's good to
say oh hold on now wait a minute hey hey
hey Max get out the way get me all wet
man I got a new jacket on all right all
right now big fell they got me all wet
you all wet how does this feel franchise
record personal record how's it feel
feels good I me uh credit to all these
guys um extremely unselfish people uh
you know I got got you know like I said
sish teammates and you know they just
got me the ball and you know I was hot
and uh they make sure that that put me
in the best position you know credit to
the coaching staff too so you know I'm
just Sur amazing people the other night
you had a big game against the Joker
y'all had a conversation after the game
tonight wmy comes in here how is it
different to prepare for Joker than get
prepared for wmy man n i dude is uh
something else obviously he got he got
all the talent in the world and you know
he's he's a man
so you know you have a great game today
um you know he's going to be you know he
has a bright future big picture Maxi's
playing well I know your bench is banged
up tonight how far can this team really
go uh man we we got a long way to go uh
it's hard to say uh but the key for us
is to stay healthy so you know we going
to do the best job possible uh you know
anything can happen uh but I think we
just want to focus on ourselves and you
know be healthy and play our best
basketball appreciate go enjoy this with
your family all right guys embiid
MVP Dennis's crowd witnesses to history
tonight we will witness to history and
what is an astonishing performance for
Mr Joel
embiid as we see 3D over there still wet
from his interview but we definitely got
a chance to witness history great
performance and you just knew right from
the start it was going to be one of
those special type of nights and be just
had that look in
ey